hey my guest tonight was of course a
cast member on saturday night live and
he's the star of the nbc series brooklyn
nine-nine his latest film which is
fantastic palm springs is streaming
right now on hulu thrilled he's on the
show please welcome andy
sandberg andy thank you for being with
us thank you very much for having me
uh i'm excited to see whose mic is
warmer
uh i think mine this might just be is
this a real mic or is this a prop
it's a real mic wow uh mine is a real
mic i
i didn't know we i got this from larry
king years ago
uh your mic is very nice it looks like
you're taking an online course right now
yeah i was saying it's like somewhere
between that and uh
infowars
it's all going to [ __ ] i don't know i've
never seen them before as i
said i don't know what they say yeah i
like it yeah doing an impression of
something you've never seen
that's how i got snl it's pretty
you did impressions of people that you
didn't really know
yeah yeah i was like this is george bush
were like no no here's my humphrey
bogart i've never seen his work but
come on guys let's get going
um it's actually not too far off no
towards the end that's what he was doing
um i like to start by asking people
because i i care actually i've been
instructed to act like i care
how are you andy how are you doing
during quarantine how's your family
uh what's going on conan thank you for
asking
uh you know
not great but great are you getting
through it okay
i'm i compared to what everyone's going
through i have no complaints but you
know
it turns out being in a quarantine sucks
yeah
um i'm you know missing seeing friends
and family and
and going to work and going to the park
but otherwise you know i don't have any
active
real complaints i'm getting i would
think one plus side
is your wife uh the beautiful
joanna newsom is an incredibly talented
musician harpist yes you least in
quarantine
get to hear wonderful music all day yes
it's true i'm almost spoiled by it you
know i get to hear her play and
and practice and stuff because she's got
to stay in harp shape
which is a thing that she tells me is a
real thing right
um but i'm like kind of by
being married to her and hearing her
play a lot i've gotten a little bit
snobby about
like other harp music now oh really yeah
so like
i'll like be like a high tea you know at
a fancy hotel and there will be a
harpist and i'll be like
sucks
do you ever say that to the harpist no
no yeah on the way out i'll be like oh
that was really beautiful
yeah great harp to joanna i'll be like
she's like i thought it was fine i'm
like yeah i was all just like [ __ ]
glissandos
no technique no one's talks that way
about the harp you know what's nice is
art music heart music is what they
always play when someone's falling in
love or having a magical epiphany and
you must constantly be walking around
the house
feeling like you're hearing that music
and thinking
falling in love with your toothbrush as
you put the paste on you know what i
mean
yeah it definitely lends itself to to
sort of
uh dissonant moments where it'll be like
playing and then i'll catch myself in
the mirror and be like
i do have to go to the bathroom
this is a magical discovery and then
i'll i'll
go do that you know uh you're lucky that
your
uh talented wife plays uh you know as an
expert
uh harp player yeah my wife uh when i
met her was in the traveling company of
stomp
and so she all she does is stomp
all day to keep in stomp shape right
she's constantly making stomping sounds
and stomping and i'm like do you really
need to do this
yeah she's like i've got to keep this up
i've got to be ready
so every time the phone rings at home
she's like is it stump yeah if
it stomped or they want me back and i
went no there's a pandemic
and no no one's seeing stomp right now
she's like well
when the this pandemic's over i'll be
stomping again
yeah uh that's how my wife talks she
sounds like her yeah
she's like you know the football the the
quarterback in high school
she was the quarterback she was yeah she
was very she was very good
the quarterback of stomp yeah
welcome to my bad improv she was also
a hamburger uh you're how old is your
daughter now
three three years old does she emulate
your wife at all is she interested in
music
yeah you know uh there's a company lion
and healy that makes harps
and when uh when it got out that we had
had a kid they very nicely sent a very
tiny lion and healey child harp to us as
a gift
right to us to her uh
and you know it's in the house now so
yeah my daughter does sometimes get on
there and sort of start strumming it and
emulating her mom it's it's pretty cute
that's sweet
yeah does she emulate and emulate you in
any way
can you do is your daughter ever like to
do things that you do
um i feel like it's only a matter of
time before she starts you know playing
the harp and doing some dick wraps
[Laughter]
i feel like that's definitely what
joanna's side of the family is waiting
for
they're gonna be stoked when that hits
a great combination yeah i think that's
what the world needs more of
yes yes certainly not less of because
there's none of it now
it's gonna be yeah i'll be it's gonna be
an interesting time when she discovers
what i have done for a living
for a load these many years um my kids
still don't know
they think i'm a realtor uh you know
yeah i have a very fond memory
when your daughter was born days
afterwards
and it surprised me but you brought her
on my show do you remember that
i did yeah that was a very special
moment i was very proud new daddy
yeah and uh i wanted to show her off
yeah yeah you did show her off
let's take a look at that clip right now
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
huh yeah yeah was she she wasn't injured
was she
she was fine she was fine you know i was
i was earning that dad of the year mug
that day
[Laughter]
hey is this right because you're so busy
you're doing so many things and i do
want to uh
i mean between brooklyn nine-nine and uh
and
this terrific movie which i wanna talk
to you about which is
i'm gonna say this um i love this film i
really do
and it's one of my favorite movies that
i've seen in during this
whole quarantine and i'm watching
classics like yeah lawrence of arabia
and uh you know citizen kane um
i loved everything about it it's a great
story the performances are incredible
uh and it was funny and it was also very
sweet
and then i noticed that you're an
executive producer
in the movie and i thought that must be
kind of cool to be in the film but also
be executive producing it or is it
difficult uh it's a lot of work
you know it was a small movie with a
small budget but
the the pluses for me outweigh the
minuses and
a big part of that for me as an actor is
i can kind of just try stuff out and
then
when i watch the edit and feel
humiliated i can just demand as a
producer that it'd be cut
you know
so it's kind of like it's it's a chill
vibe for me to bring to the table
yeah but that's you know that's how i
that's kind of how i've been rolling the
last few years it's kind of i call it
the andre brower rule
you know where i'm a producer on
brooklyn too where i'm like just
surround me with good actors
and then we'll get in the edit and then
anytime i suck we'll just cut to the
good actor
so yeah the cast is terrific they really
are in this movie
yeah you you guys all seem to work out
and then you got the incredible
uh uh jk simmons yeah in this
and i mean the man's won an oscar and
and he's jonah jameson
and he's also jonah jameson and the
spider-man series yeah
yeah i i try to get him to talk to me as
jonah jameson a lot
be like call me pretend i'm peter parker
and be jonah jamison and he's like what
no i'm not gonna do that
and i'd be like do my outgoing uh
voicemail as jonah jameson be like i
need pictures of spiderman
he's like i'm not going to do that get
out of my trailer
[Laughter]
you're yeah you just sound like not a
good executive producer
i was like yeah i'm a producer you have
to
for your fire yeah
uh you know we have a clip here um
tell us what's happening in this clip in
case anyone doesn't know this is early
on in the film
and yes i did use the word film thank
you it was at sundance
big deal for me um it's early on in the
field
you have a little gas did you have a
little gas there
sorry this is one of my daughter's hair
clips just nervously picking up
okay uh yes early on in the film
uh and you don't yet know
unless you watch the trailer that my
character has been uh reliving the same
day many times
uh and i'm i'm courting kristen
milliotti's character sarah
and sort of gliding through the uh the
wedding and doing some dancing
uh let's take a look at this clip from
palm springs oh yeah
[Music]
so
[Music]
and we're gonna show it
you know what's awkward about these
interviews that we do
is that when you come on the real show
yeah we then show to the clip
and it's a really good clip and the
audience would like it and then they
would applaud and we'd come back from it
yeah but when we shoot this we add the
clip later on
so you didn't see the clip and i didn't
see the clip we both know what the clip
is
in this moment it's so fake yeah so fake
i go let's take a look
and then it's just you and me going and
then i go wow
that was great but we didn't just see
anything we didn't see it can we
pretend like the clip just ended again
and then you guys can put in
applause and we can do the like normal
thing and i'll just say
i'll take a sip of my water like it just
came out of the clip okay let's take a
look at this uh clip
uh from uh from palm springs
[Music]
we're back wow
yeah i mean it's a fun movie
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i miss that stuff i miss those little
things what is it
no you're a you're a smart guy and
you're behind the scenes in the
business oh um
when do you think we people get back to
acting and making things again
how's it going how's it going i i have a
feeling
like it can go one of two ways right
we'll get it under control there's a
vaccine
or we come up with some great protocol
that actually feels safe
or and hear me out
everything goes mocap motion capture
and we all get like ready player one
style mocap
rigs in our homes and you can audition
this way
and then actually shoot this way it's
like avatar style but it's like
everyone's in their own home robert
camiro's in his home wearing a motion
capture suit you're in your home
yeah and like ready player one
with a diaper because you know you don't
want to waste time by leaving set
so we all have our you know that's also
from ready player one the book
not for all you you know posers who just
like
saw the movie they cut out the diaper
thing oh pretty bs also the virtual sex
they cut out
such a sellout spielberg unbelievable
anyway but yeah i think you know if you
if you could get like a really good
mocap rig and like a little blue screen
or green screen
room in your house right with one of
those you know 360 cameras
and a diaper a big old diaper yeah like
a big like
multiple trips diaper you know wait so
you'd be using the diaper over and over
and over again without changing it
yeah so you can just shoot for days you
know like in ready player won the book
not the movie which was a sellout
okay um yeah i did like the movie though
yeah i like the movie yeah
that was a good move you still get to be
in the business
um you know i wanted to mention uh i'm
here
shooting these last couple of weeks here
at largo fargo
and uh we we wanted to take over a space
and
uh there goes andy richter sneaking by
hey
[Laughter]
going back to the dressing rooms there
yeah going back to the dressing rooms
that's right thanks sandy
who is that that's andy sandberg he has
no idea how
he didn't sell palm springs last night
it was really awesome
thanks man i really liked it whoa that's
pretty close he has no
idea who's on the show he comes in he
doesn't know i'm shooting an interview
he's going to go to that little bathroom
at the end of the hall little bathroom
at the end of the hall
what kind of operation we're running
here
like any minute now chickens are just
going to come running across did you
guys
did you guys discuss maybe doing it on
the stage looking out
you like the backstage better because of
all that no no the stage is right
the audience is right here yeah i never
i don't think i ever got up there
i always wanted to i didn't stand up you
know back in the day but yeah
well maybe you will maybe uh you'll come
back here once this place reopens
or you could just appear here in a
motion capture suit from your own home
as you're into a diaper political diaper
yeah
[Laughter]
you bleep the bleep the curses or do you
let the curses roll
man it's pandemic we let it all hang
out that's cool how many curses
how many curses would i have to say to
start getting bleeped i don't know i
i actually have no idea i have no idea
but who could stop us
anymore it's [ __ ] true in the ass
[ __ ] diaper
taking a big old dumpy [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] moccasin
oh man this is punk rock this is the
cbgb's of
[Music]
he's been in that bathroom for a long
time yeah
richter to be he says he's out okay here
we go
now okay um well anyway uh
let me get the word out on palm springs
okay thank you
thank you palm springs is available to
stream on hulu
and uh i promise you it is a it is one
of the better movies you're going to see
uh for quite a while so see that
film and really terrific performances
and heart warming and i'm very happy for
you
because you're also you're just terrific
in this movie
and uh i just know that this is this is
a big deal
this is a great movie so thank you to
you congratulations
seriously very happy thank you thanks
buddy and i look forward to seeing you
uh
in person so we can do this with our
hands and fingers we should see each
other in person
i i'm not good with hand signals
that was not subtle each other
is that the right one i've never
understood hand signals going
andy sandberg thank you very much thank
you buddy